in with rocky she is giving us a sneak
peek at the black farmers market today
something you can enjoy and support
every saturday this february for black
history month
it is all about spreading black love
here at the black farmers market for
february and beyond i would say a cowboy
bay shane you're the owner of cowboy bay
why are you deciding to spread love to
the community this is a great way for us
to partner with members of the community
and not only are we hosting the event
all month but we have a now hiring booth
here so we've got 500 positions for the
water park come out and get a summer job
that is amazing thank you shane let's
move over to sierra now to introduce us
to our next two businesses for black
farmers market here we have aliyah she
is the owner of luna loveness she
creates intention candles oils and
crystals
and it smells good but since you are a
healer you're setting intentions what
should we know for 2022 for 2022 we
should focus more on self-love because
as we love ourself more we will
illuminate that to other people in the
community hey man that was beautiful
your website for people to get more
information lunalovnest.com well thank
you luna loveness okay moving on now to
vegas style sierra introduce me so we
here we have cevante and gary and they
are the owners of vegas style which is
an apparel company okay because i
already want a hat a t-shirt a beanie
let us know more information about you
guys you can find us at vegas style dot
vegas that's vegas style dot vegas if
you don't see it here we have it out
here saturday ready set vegas let's go
ready set vegas let's go i love that and
like you said if you don't see it here
you'll see it on saturday because this
is not the only thing that will be here
on saturday you have 30 plus businesses
right correct 30 plus businesses food
vendors farmers we've got everything a
kidzone just come out and enjoy the day
and i hear there's a kissing booth you
know to keep that to keep that
valentine's day energy absolutely we'll
have a kissing booth here exactly i love
it's all about spreading black love and
love in general love for all and i will
send it back to you
love it thank you so much rocky las
vegas now